Halloween is fast approaching and it's
bringing a ton of new horror movies to
terrify you here's how the theaters will
trick and treat you this Halloween the
nun the conjuring universe is screaming
back into theaters with the nun which
will add some backstory to one of
conjuring twos most terrifying
characters a priest joins forces with a
young nun in Romania to investigate a
death at a remote probably haunted Abbey
in the mountains you can bet they'll
come face-to-face with a few unholy
Horrors creeping around those dark
hallways and they are having none of it
American horror stories taissa farmiga
plays the lead with Bonnie Aaron's
returning as the demonic nun Bala the
nun will return to scare the poo out of
you on September 7 Mandy when critics
rave that Nicolas Cage gave the
performance of a lifetime you know it's
something special
crazy evil from writer-director Panos
cosmatos mandy is a tale of backwoods
revenge that pushes the horror envelope
in ways few filmmakers would even
attempt read and mandy lead an isolated
existence deep in the woods
that is until mandy breaks that cardinal
rule of camping she attracts the
attention of a psychotic cult leader
obviously things go bad
leading red to embark on a spree of drug
fuelled vengeance
behold the insanity when mandy debuts
September 14th Halloween remakes and
reboots of classic horror franchises
haven't exactly been cinematic gold in
recent years but Halloween might be the
horror movie that finally violently
breaks the mold eastbound and down star
Danny McBride and producer David Gordon
Green came together to work on the
concept for the new film which they
pitched directly to the franchise's
original creator John Carpenter who
loved it even though he never wanted a
sequel in the first place
why this time it's pretending the other
sequels didn't happen this new film
takes place after the events of the 1978
original and judging by the trailers
Halloween is going to be pure terror
take a look when it hits theaters on
October 19 Overlord a world war 2 set
horror outing from JJ Abrams bad robot
production company Overlord asks the
question what's worse than dropping into
a Nazi filled war zone simple dropping
into a Nazi filled war zone along with
goopy zombie monsters the movie follows
some American paratroopers who land in
nazi-occupied France and find themselves
fighting for their lives against
bloodthirsty monsters since this is a
bad robot production it wasn't long
before rumors started flying that
Overlord was yet another stealth entry
in the Cloverfield universe
despite the speculation JJ Abrams says
it definitely isn't and that's totally
ok a world war 2 survival horror movie
sounds like a great time all by itself
check it out when overlord premieres on
November 9th the predator the original
predator immersed audiences in an
exciting blend of sci-fi action and
horror and the sequel looks like it's
going back to those tear
buying roots co-writer and director
Shane Black promises that the predator
will carry a hard r-rating giving the
alien hunter free rein to do what it
does best kill loads of guys
the film's suburban setting should
provide even more opportunities for
thrills because the scariest monster is
the one in your own backyard and we
don't mean your weird uncle Charlie
activate your heat vision and look for
the predator in theaters on September 14
venom while it may not be a horror movie
in the classic sense venom is shaping up
into something terrifying director Ruben
Fleischer is promising a horror tinged
film with a venom who isn't afraid to
get bloody and chomp on a few heads lady
snakes
all signs point to Sony getting things
right with their second crack at the
deadly symbiote and we'll see just how
right when venom hits theaters on
October 5th
[Music]